[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
auditions publiques une heure en invité
tous les lundis à 19h30 sur LCP et
Public Sénat pour scanner toute
l'actualité politique avec un invité
aujourd'hui la 34 ans notre invité le
président 13 stratégie commission des
lois à l'Assemblée nationale bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ancien militants
socialiste macroniste de la première
heure comme on dit député de la Vienne
vous êtes considéré comme un pilier de
la majorité il n'empêche vous avez voté
contre la vie de l'exécutif pour la
taxation des super dividendes est une
posture ou le signe que vous n'êtes pas
tout à fait ou pas toujours en phase
avec l'exécutif êtes-vous inquiet pour
les réformes retraites immigration
sécurité énergies renouvelable alors que
vous avez quasiment épuisé votre réserve
de 49-3 on va parler dans un instant
Steve Jourdain et Brigitte boucher
passeront au crible les épreuves qui
vous attendent le gouvernement et vous
la majorité au Parlement est-ce que
l'alliance avec la droite et votre une
planche de salut pour durer question
tout à l'heure d'iftréa Vincent roux
reviendra sur deux sujets d'actualité
qui animent la rédaction du Figaro et
vous débattrez merci d'avoir accepté
avec les lulfi Antoine léoman non en
particulier en parlera des salaires mais
d'abord cette question puisque c'est
l'actualité elle est toute fraîche elle
s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale il y
a quelques minutes Elisabeth borne est
monté la tribune de l'hémicycle pour
annoncer ceci
mesdames et messieurs les députés sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la troisième partie du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est la troisième partie de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale la partie dépense peu importe ce
qui nous frappe c'est que le texte vient
d'arriver dans l'hémicycle fini de rire
fini de jouer c'est plus la peine de
passer du temps à parler avec les
oppositions tout de suite le 49-3 est
dégainé par le gouvernement qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de surprenant sur un texte
budgétaire à constater que nous n'avons
pas la majorité qu'est-ce que on
découvre finalement que sur le budget
les oppositions ne nous ont fait aucun
cadeau ni les oppositions républicaines
et à forceillery moins encore les
oppositions qui sont les plus radicales
qu'est-ce qui a changé entre la première
lecture et le passage au Sénat qui
justifierait que nous n'utilisions pas
le 49-3 pour cette nouvelle lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale puisque c'est de
cela dont il s'agit bon on est pas
surpris l'utilisation du 49-tra sur un
texte ordinaire comme nous ne l'avons
sur l'énergie renouvelable sur la loi
d'orientation du ministère intérieur sur
le texte l'immigration ça par contre ce
serait une nouveauté puisque jusqu'à
présent ça n'est pas arrivé et donc sur
les textes budgétaires en revanche on
sait qu'on a un front unique entre nous
un Frau uni contre les mesures de
prévention un front uni contre la
contraception gratuite dans tout le pays
un front unique contre les mesures qui
facilitent l'implantation des médecins
ou en tout cas qui répondent à la crise
qu'on connaît dans l'accès à des
médecins dans notre pays un front uni
finalement contre toutes les mesures qui
sont susceptibles et bien d'améliorer la
vie des Français et donc face à ce front
unique comme en première lecture nous
utilisons l'article 49 aliments n'a que
ce qu'elle mérite un régime minceur sur
les textes budgétaires dans la
discussion en réalité pour que les
choses changent il faudrait l'opposition
change aussi change aussi sa méthode et
présente des amendements qui pourraient
être adoptés et je vais vous dire une
chose on pourra y revenir mais
typiquement la meilleure le meilleur
exemple que nous ne sommes pas bornés et
je dis nous
Parlement majorité et gouvernement c'est
que entre l'examen du projet de loi de
finance rectificatif cet été et l'examen
du projet de loi de finance initial pour
2023 et bien il n'y avait pas de taxe
sur les super-profis et il y a désormais
une taxe sur les supports super profits
à l'initiative de député de la majorité
pour mettre en place la contribution
exceptionnelle européenne mais la
réalité c'est que les choses peuvent
bouger et elles peuvent bouger
sensiblement puisque cette taxe qui
devait rapporter initialement 200
millions d'euros on estime désormais que
c'est entre 7 et 11 milliards d'euros
donc ça veut dire que on peut faire
bouger des choses quand on est
parlementaire on peut faire bouger les
choses y compris quand au départ on
n'est pas forcément d'accord avec le
gouvernement de sorte que les
oppositions pourraient s'en saisir aussi
et puis participer à cette
œuvre constructive je voudrais vous
montrer la une du point vous l'avez
peut-être vu elle vous a peut-être
frappé un président zombie c'est le
titre pourquoi parce que pas de majorité
peu d'allier et des secousses qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de fou là-dedans tout est vrai
pas de majorité des secouss le président
zombie vous êtes d'accord sur le constat
oui sur l’analyse non parce que quel est
le constat est-ce que nous n'avons pas
de majorité parce que nous avons une
majorité relative depuis le mois de juin
oui est-ce que il y a des secousses dans
le pays oui comme partout en Europe
l'inflation est forte oui comme partout
en Europe on subit une grande crise de
l'énergie oui comme partout en Europe on
est attaqué par la Russie sur le
territoire européen donc ce coup ça
existe et des alliés qui sont
récalcitrant oui quand je vois la droite
qui s'époumone parce qu'en fait
finalement on ferait des mesures sur
l'immigration qu'ils auraient voulu
faire quand je vois la gauche qui
finalement s'étouffe alors même que le
plan de régularisation des sans-papiers
des travailleurs irréguliers et bien ils
n'ont jamais fait autant bah pardon je
me dis que on pourrait quand même
compter sur eux sur ces mesures et que
malheureusement ils font défaut un mot
encore parce qu'on sait ici que vous
êtes fan de foot le Mondial a commencé
hier la FIFA a fait d'une certaine façon
la Fédération internationale de foot
plier les capitaines des différentes
équipes qui renoncent finalement à
porter un brassard arc-en-ciel en
solidarité avec le mouvement LGBT la
FIFA leur a proposé sombre à ça et
finalement ils ont dit oui vous le
regrettez ça dit beaucoup de la main
mise de la FIFA et l'UEFA qui sont des
organisations aujourd'hui qui ont des
fonctionnements scandaleux avec des
dérives que j'ose qualifiées de mafieuse
on a même vu dans l'organisation de
matchs européen et j'ai pour cela des
comptes-rendus des préfectures de police
ou des préfectures françaises qui
indiquent comment procèdent l'UEFA et
les instances européennes du foot
mondial et je dis que ces instances
elles doivent changer leurs pratiques et
que les gouvernements doivent mettre
tous leurs poids pour ce changement
parce que effectivement imposer ce genre
de choses décider de l'attribution de la
Coupe du Monde d'abord en Russie en 2018
ensuite au Qatar en 2022 et bien ça
appelle à des responsabilités est-ce
qu'on est des exigences très fortes à
leur regard
non parce qu'il y a une grande
hypocrisie dans le boycot d'abord je me
rendrai pas au Qatar ça c'est une
certitude en revanche je regarderai les
matchs de l'équipe nationale et il y a
une forme d'hypocrisie aujourd'hui à
dire ah bah ça n'est que maintenant que
l'on se réveille et puis que finalement
on regarderait pas du match serait que
ce serait un peu confortable cette
ce boycott du canapé finalement un
boycot du canapé vous vous serez dans
votre canapé vous regarderez le match
vous le regardez sur votre téléphone
il vaut mieux pas pour la bonne tenue
des travaux
c'est à vous alors ce matin Olivier du
soft a dévoilé aux partenaires sociaux
les nouvelles règles de l'assurance
chômage donc une durée d'indemnisation
qui réduite de 25% et ce dès le premier
février parce que le taux de chômage est
inférieur à 9% c'est le taux référence
qui a été retenu est-ce que vous étiez
au courant ou est-ce que vous découvrez
ces détails de la réforme sur les
mesures en tout cas sur les
l'application des modalités non je les
découvre en même temps que vous mais ça
ne surprend pas puisque c'est
l'autorisation que nous avons donné au
gouvernement l'autorisation qui est de
dire quand le marché se contracte quand
effectivement il y a moins d'emplois et
bien dans ces cas-là dans cette
hypothèse et bien on plus généreux avec
les chômeurs et on augmente la durée
d'indemnisation chômage pourquoi parce
que c'est une assurance et quand le
risque est plus élevé et bien
l'assurance est plus généreuse
d'ailleurs la modification la
modification des règles que vous avez la
gueule de bois ce matin non je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que on peut on peut
venir de la gauche et aussi avoir une
une certaine idée de l'assurance chômage
et de la solidarité et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi d'abord parce que les
règles de 2008 c'est Nicolas Sarkozy qui
les avait changé précisément parce qu'on
avait un choc mondial qui était la crise
des subprimes et qui a généré beaucoup
de chômage dans notre pays ensuite parce
que depuis 2008 et principalement plutôt
depuis 2015 on observe une baisse
progressive du chômage une baisse du
chômage qui passait de 10% en 2015
notamment aujourd'hui pour les
territoires comme le mien pour la Vienne
5% à tel point que il y a
7,6,3 effectivement et donc il y a des
endroits où on est au plein emploi et où
les employeurs peinent à recruter ou on
peine
finalement à placer placer des gens donc
on a besoin de cette de ces disposition
qui vivifie le marché du travail qu'il
faut revivre et puis on a eu des
garanties si ça allait mal de nouveau
donc si le taux de chômage atteignait
9%. si le taux de chômage s'est levé de
0,8 % sur une année un trimestre pardon
dans ces cas-là on pourra avoir un
retour des mesures qui sont plus
généreuses
généralisée c'est ce qu'on appelle un
choc et pour le coup pour le dérac de
l'indemnisation et pour le coup c'est ce
choc qui en 2008 avait justifié une
assurance chômage plus géniale une
assurance chômage une assurance
c'est très bien que là le taux de
chômage ne va pas durablement revenir
au dessus des 9%, ça veut dire que c'est
l'exception devient la règle pourquoi
pourquoi on le sait parce que
précisément mais en oeuvre beaucoup de
mesures pour que les gens trouvent du
travail parce qu'on fait en sorte que le
travail paye mieux parce qu'on fait en
sorte que il y ait des primes à l'emploi
et notamment que l'activité elle soit
toujours mieux rémunéré que l'inactivité
parce qu'on fait en sorte que il y a des
primes Macron pour mieux payer les
salaires parce qu'on fait ensemble que
les supplémentaires soient défiscalisés
sous-entend quand même que les gens
pourraient retrouver un petit peu plus
vite du travail alors est-ce que vous
réduisez la durée d'indemnisation ça
veut dire que si on se donne un peu de
mal on peut trouver je conduis quand
même les choses
pour
toucher l'assurance chômage il faut être
travaillé 8 mois sur 24 8 mois sur 24
est-ce que est-ce que c'est mesures sont
antisociales moi je dis non bah dis non
8 mois sur 24 c'est normal huit mois sur
24 c'est les nouvelles mesures contre
six mois sur 28 ce qui était le cas
durcissement vous durcissez les règles
c'est un durcissement qui se justifie
par le fait que l'employé disponible et
qu'on doit pouvoir inciter au retour à
l'emploi par ailleurs il y a d'autres il
y a d'autres il y a d'autres mesures
donc il y a beaucoup aujourd'hui
français qui ne reviennent pas au
travail parce qu'ils ne le veulent pas
sous-entend qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
politique dans ce pays dans lequel des
gens peuvent prendre leur temps pour
revenir c'est légitime puisque les
règles leur permettent donc on change
les règles pour leur dire qui profite du
système mais profitez du système enfin
appliquer les règles c'est pas profité
du système appliquer derrière donc nous
on dit on constate qu'on a besoin de
retour sur l'emploi plus rapide donc on
réduit les règles d'indemnisation dans
les proportions qui sont celles que je
vous ai indiqué qui sont pas si
hydractiques qu'on veut bien le dire et
puis une autre observation c'est que
dans cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage tout le monde tout le monde a
oublié qu'il y avait un bonus Manu sur
les contrats courts vous savez que
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on constate sur
le marché de l'emploi ça veut dire que
l'emploi que l'on défend c'est un emploi
qui est non précaire si un emploi qui en
CDI c'est à deux conséquences c'est de
faire baisser l'intérim c'est de faire
baisser les CDD et c'est de faire
augmenter les embauches en CDI toutes
les statistiques dont on dispose montre
que l'emploi que nous créons c'est de
l'emploi Perrin c'est de l'emploi stable
c'est de l'emploi non précaire et ça
pardon de vous le dire effectivement en
disant on réduit les CDD on réduit les
périodes dans lesquelles il y a une
activité on essaie de faire en sorte que
les gens soient moins au chômage je
trouve que il y a une volonté sociale
que de dire que les emplois ont les des
gens en emploi Perrin et par ailleurs ça
facilite même la façon dont ils peuvent
emprunter durablement pour acheter une
maison ensuite on va parler des
retraites si vous voulez bien on a vu
les Abdes bandes qui a enclenché le 49-3
sur le budget de la Sécu un budget de la
Sécu qui avait été adopté auparavant au
Sénat un budget dans lequel les
sénateurs repoussé l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans 64 ans c'est quoi ces
petits bras vous l'avez plus loin ou
alors vous êtes mal tombé parce que moi
d'abord avant qu'on parle de des mesures
et je vous en dis je vous dirai très
sincèrement ce que j'en pense et vous en
serait peut-être surpris je vais vous
dire que pour faire une réforme de
retraite il faut d'abord dire qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire
si nous on ne veut rien faire alors on
assume qu'à m'en donner le trou sera si
important qu'on devra ou baisser les
retraites ou augmenter les impôts
celles-ci on ne veut rien faire si
maintenant on dit qu'on va assurer à
tout le monde une retraite qu'on veut
que cette retraite se soit pas des
clopinettes pas trois bouts de
chandelles et si on veut que cette
retraite elle soit au minimum de 1100
euros pour ceux qui ont travaillé toute
leur vie exactement ce qu'on a fait pour
les agriculteurs par ailleurs et bien
dans ce cas-là il faut pouvoir le
financer si on veut que ceux qui ont
commencé à 17 ans en tout cas avant 20
ans sur la philosophie de la réforme la
droite
je vais aller jusqu'au bout des choses
et je vais vous dire pourquoi je suis
pas d'accord avec la droite au Sénat
pareil alors dites-nous si on veut
financer des dispositifs de pénibilité
ou de carrière longue le fait que les
gens qui ont commencé tôt par Toto on
doit pouvoir avoir des ressources et
donc il faut trouver des renouvelles
ressources moi j'ai toujours dit que
j'étais plus favorable à le logement de
la durée de cotisation en fait on
travaille 43 ans 43 à nuités plutôt
voire même qu'on regarde sur les nombre
d'années parce que c'est plus juste
quand vous avez commencé tôt vous partez
tôt que de toucher à l'âge légal je sais
la volonté du gouvernement de vouloir
augmenter la durée de la gale je ne suis
pas ignorant sur ce sujet là c'est une
mesure c'est une mesure sur lequel j'ai
des sérieuses réserves par rapport aux
inégalités qu'elles peuvent causer et
donc avec ce qu'on discute avec le
ministère du travail notamment c'est de
savoir comment
si il décide d'augmenter l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite comment il
réduisent les inégalités pour que ceux
qui ont commencé tôt qui ont eu les
métiers difficiles voire qu'on tirait le
diable par la queue toute leur vie et
bien il soit pas les dindons de la farce
de l'âge de la retraite c'est pas une
certitude alors que c'est une promesse
de campagne du président de la
République ce que je vous dis c'est
qu'aujourd'hui moi j'ai pas les
arbitrages du gouvernement et je sais
pas quel projet il va présenter que vous
y êtes pas favorable je dis que la
mesure la plus juste en tout cas la
moins injuste c'est celle de
l'allongement de la dure cotisation
ou comme contrepartie donc ce que je dis
c'est que dans l'idéal il devrait faire
que l'allongement de la durée cotisation
et que si il décide de mesures d'âge
alors il doit présenter toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour que toutes les
inégalités qui sont générées par cette
mesure soit bon mais par exemple et ben
des départs anticipés le calcul de
pénibilité qui permet un des départs
anticipé également
et ou par ailleurs des
reports de la décote ou encore des
mesures qui permettent d'avoir des
retraites qui soient complètes juste sur
la méthode il faudra un texte spécifique
pour faire passer cette éventuelle
réforme des retraite par contre je suis
je suis tout sauf naïf je pense que
compte tenu de la difficulté de faire
passer un texte sur la retraite je ne
vois pas
je ne vois pas comment le gouvernement
fera autrement qu'un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificatif donc à 49-3 éventuelle avec
une possibilité de 49-3 mais chacun sera
mis devant ses responsabilités tout le
monde nous fait le son à longueur de
temps en disant il y a pas d'argent et
faites des économies de gestion
débrouillez-vous pour ce type et puis
personne veut voter à la fin je parle à
la droite et puis même enfin la gauche
pardon mais c'est la gauche qui a fait
l'allongement la durée de cotisation sur
la réforme qu'on appelle Touraine donc
et puis tout le monde veut qu'on vive
mieux la gauche elle veut notamment
qu'on s'occupe mieux des personnes âgées
elle veut qu'on rénove nos EHPAD elle
veut que les gens aient des droits
nouveaux moi je suis d'accord à ça
la dernière réforme des retraite et ça
suffira pas de dire les riches parce que
ça suffit pas parce qu'on a regardé qui
paye et dire que les riches d'abord il
faut définir les riches parce que
souvent ceux qui disent les riches
doivent payer à gauche ce sont les
riches de gauche d'une part et puis
d'autre part
j'aime autant vous dire que qui paye
c'est souvent une façon de dire
le cafocon et puis il faudrait que moi
je vais qu'on dise qui paye qui paye
quoi quel nouveau droit et ça c'est un
peu plus cohérent en tout cas un peu
plus honnête vis-à-vis des gens qui nous
écoutent on va passer à l'immigration à
présent depuis ce weekend il y a une
centaine de rescapés de la chaîne viking
qui sont dans la nature suite à une
décision de justesse administrative il y
a aussi 26 mineurs sur les 44 qui ont
fugué est-ce que la situation est hors
de contrôle pour le gouvernement non
d'abord enfin moi je vois la démarche
qui est entreprise par toute une série
de politiques pour dire nous n'aurions
pas dû accueillir le sein de Viking
d'accord donc faire mourir ces gens en
mer
c'est ça et c'est la question à laquelle
n'ont pas répondu ni la droite ni
l'extrême droite dans l'hémicycle
lorsqu'ils ont été interpellés à ce
sujet par le ministre de l'Intérieur pas
de réponse fallait les styles laissez
mourir ces personnes en mer pas de
réponse donc oui il fallait les
accueillir c'est une fierté de la France
elle l'a fait par ailleurs elle a aussi
posé des questions des mesures de de
rétorsion vis-à-vis de l'Italie parce
que c'était à l'Italie d'ailleurs ce
bateau normalement et à partir du moment
où l'Italie ne respecte pas les règles
européennes de répartition d'accueil
même les règles internationales de
sauvetage en mer et bien on est en droit
de fermer la frontière et de ne pas
accueillir les 3500 personnes qu'on
avait promis d'accueillir et voyez la
proportion 243
c'est assez intéressant et c'est assez
clairant pour notre débat sur la loi sur
l'immigration on a accueilli des mineurs
on enferme beaucoup des mineurs
donc si les mineurs veulent partir ils
sont libres de le faire en France on
enferme pas des mineurs voilà c'est
possible dans le droit mais on ne le
fait quasiment plus on va certainement
l'interdire dans le texte sur
l'immigration ensuite pour les majeurs
66 personnes ont été directement admises
à l'asile leurs dossiers ont été étudiés
sur le champ 123 ne l'ont pas été et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec et donc il y a
eu des recours il y a eu des appels et
toute la procédure était tellement
embolisée on a monté une paralysie des
tribunaux judiciaires ce n'est pas un
reproche qu'on fait au tribunal
judiciaire on connaît les limites des
moyens sur ce sujet et ça a montré
surtout
le fait que la procédure qu'on a mis en
place est totalement dépassée parce
qu'on sait que en matière d'immigration
en termes d'asile on a 12 procédures
différentes on a des recours
et vous nous aviez à peu près la même
chose au moment de la loi de vous dire
que tous les amendements qui
permettaient de réformer ce point ont
été écartés par un ministre dont
j'essaie de me souvenir non ah oui
Gérard Collomb le même qui nous donne
des leçons aujourd'hui donc il est très
bien placé pour nous donner le sang
puisqu'il a précisément pas fait ce
qu'on aurait dû faire et ce que nous on
lui avait proposé à ce moment-là avec
les moyens de faire ce qu'il voulait
faire
sur ce sujet les amendements Dupont les
amendements Cariou les amendement relax
il aurait très bien pu les prendre il
disait la même chose cela réduction des
délais sur la réduction des procédures
sur le titre de régularisation des
travailleurs réguliers qui aujourd'hui
sont ceux qui vous servent sont ceux qui
vous soignent ou sont ceux qui
construisent
donc vous le reconnaissez c'était une
nouvelle fois les mesures qui étaient
intéressantes et les mesures qui
sont quand on a quand on a choisi une
prime de mieux protéger les victimes
décisions quand on a choisi de mieux
accueillir pour le regroupement
regroupement familial quand on a choisi
de donner des cours de français on en a
choisi de pouvoir avoir des mesures sur
sur l'immigration irrégulière et
notamment très restrictive à l'égard des
passeurs c'est des mesures qui ont été
utilisées
si vous me le permettez mais très vite
parce qu'on a encore trois sujets et il
y aurait 5 minutes
lorsqu'elle est d'origine étrangère
c'est un des points du ministre de
l'Intérieur ensuite pour effectivement
avoir des titres de séjour et enfin pour
réduire les délais des juridictions on
va passer aux énergies renouvelables il
y a un projet de loi qui a été adopté
par le Sénat encore ce week-end le texte
va être examiné à l'Assemblée nationale
les députés alerte demandent un droit de
veto pour les maires en cas
d'implantation pauv vous rigolez parce
que les sénateurs et l'air n'ont pas
voté
c'est à dire parce que parce que
précisément oui mais les députés à l'air
se demandent maintenant un droit de veto
pour les mers en cas d'implantation de
projet d'éolienne une réponse politique
innovation pragmatique bon d'abord les
députés LR il faut qu'ils s'entende
inverse leurs amis des députés les
sénateurs et l'air qui ont voté le
contraire en disant on a des mesures
dans les plans d'urbanisme qui pourront
réserver des zones dans lesquelles on va
implanter des éoliennes ce sera la main
tous les élus locaux qui vont se
concentrer ça c'est une réponse
politique d'accord je suis mère je suis
merde une petite commune je sais que à
côté de ma commune il y a une église qui
est classée etc je vais mettre des
éoliennes
juste en liseré de ma commune donc
l'autre maire il pourra rien dire moi je
prends 5000 euros par eliotienne JE SUIS
TRANQUILLE les invitants de mon village
ils ont pas d'éolienne qu'est-ce que ça
va changer de mettre un droit de veto
pour le maire de la commune d'à côté
rien qu'est-ce que la mesure a donné un
cas limite qu'est-ce que généralement
qu'est-ce que la mesure du Sénat va
changer par rapport à ça il y a une
définition en commun des zones entre
élus ou effectivement en bord de
l'autoroute lorsque l'on a des friches
lorsqu'on a des anciennes décharges
alors lorsqu'on a des endroits où
finalement l'intérêt est assez moins
dans ta esthétique ou paysager et bien
on peut implanter des éoliennes après
moi je vais vous dire une chose tout le
monde se focus qu'aujourd'hui des
éoliennes terrestres le plan qu'on a
choisi le plan zéro carbone la France 0
carbone 2050 qui prévoit 50 parcs
d'éolien en mer le doublement des
éoliennes terrestres et donc on voit
bien que les éoliennes qui vont être
renforcés c'est d'abord les aliens et
surtout
mais les voix de la droite il faut aussi
prendre ses responsabilités
on veut pas de gaz russe on veut pas de
pétrole on veut pas de charbon on fait
comment
50% des entrées 50 % de nucléaire dans
notre production énergétique
par contre il faut voter le paquet il
faut voter l'ensemble d'accord
demain début octobre Emmanuel Macron
avait promis une vraie décentralisation
qu'est-ce que c'est une vraie
décentralisation est-ce qu'il y a un
texte est déjà dans les tuyaux non parce
que pour le coup il y a une consultation
qui doit pouvoir voir le jour et puis
une vraie décentralisation c'est quelque
chose qui est négocié c'est quelque
chose dans lequel on discute de ce qui
peut être transféré ou commune au
département ou région c'est pas quelque
chose que l'on leur impose donc de ce
point de vue là
oui 4 ans et demi même un petit peu plus
longtemps donc sur ces questions là on a
une urgence absolue qui est celle des
ressources des communes d'ailleurs les
ressources des communes on peut observer
qu'il y a une augmentation de la DGF de
310 millions dans lequel je n'inclus pas
les deux milliards et demi qui sont ceux
de l'aide
vraiment sur la descente c'est ce qui
m'intéressait ce que je vais vous dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui je vais pas vous
faire des annonces ici depuis Paris en
vous disant ça doit être comme ça que ça
doit être Emmanuel
il fera pas de discours qu'est-ce qu'il
va y faire justement mais c'est aussi
c'est aussi une nouveauté on vient on a
vous vous souvenez des années
précédentes on a reproché au président
de la République de dire il vient il
nous fait son grand discours il s'en va
et puis c'est terminé il va pas les voir
sur leur terrain les légumes et les
langues qui avaient dit que c'était un
dîner de cons souvenez bon après on a
été servi par le par cet élémentaire
consulter écoutez et puis voir ce qu'il
peut s'y peut enfin vous venez de me
dire on a pas de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale donc
a priori on va pas plaquer notre vision
de la décentralisation et dire c'est
comme ça et on va avoir des
consultations des différents
associations d'élus départements commune
région et puis on va voir comment on
peut
voir si un jour il peut d'ici 2027 faire
une loi des centralisation
qui est le président du groupe modem va
redéposer son amendement sur les super
dividendes est-ce que vous allez le
voter si l'examinez oui et pas de raison
que je change d'avis entre en cours de
route sur cette idée d'abord
qu'est-ce que c'est l'amendement de
Jean-Paul Mathilde dont tout le monde
parle c'est l'idée de dire lorsqu'on
fait un surprofit une surdividence donc
lorsque on a un excès de rémunération
soit on peut
réintégrer l'entreprise réinvestir dans
l'entreprise se surprofit soit si on
décide de le prendre pour soi si on
donne aux actionnaires il est taxé non
plus à 30%, ils sont que c'est un peu
plus à 35 % bon est-ce que c'est
révolutionnaire non c'est ce que l'État
a fait en tant qu'actionnaire principal
de DF pendant 5 ans quand il dégageait
de la marge quand il dégageait des
gouvernement et bien il réinvestissait
il transformait en titre ce qui a permis
ensuite la nationalisation d'EDF alors
je pense qu'il faut encore les les coins
de sur certaines choses mais
on avance c'est exactement l'exemple que
je vous donnais tout à l'heure sur la
question des des supers profits et je
voyais que j'ai fait de l'abscisse en
réalité tout à l'heure
c'était pas question à l'automne c'était
dans le PLF prenez la taxe sur le
carburant des avions allaiter son année
de pas question à l'automne c'était dans
le PLF donc il y a une mission il y a
une mission du parti Renaissance confié
à Pascal Camphin il y a des travaux à
l'Assemblée nationale confia au député
Louis Marguerite il y a évidemment une
détermination du modèle d'aller au bout
sur le partage de la valeur je leur dis
moi je suis beau
merci beaucoup Brigitte et Steve à la
semaine prochaine dans un instant
illustral d'abord Vincent roux en direct
du Figaro live bonjour Vincent qui va
vous poser une question d'actualité
c'est à VOUS Vincent
bonsoir Sacha Ollier je sais pas si vous
êtes au courant mais ce soir il y a un
débat entre les candidats à la
présidence LR
est-ce que ça vous intéresse
bah oui oui évidemment pour savoir quel
sera la ligne du parti républicains dans
les prochaines années j'ai vu que il y
avait une ligne qui s'était beaucoup
droitisée à l'occasion de choix du
candidat à l'élection présidentielle et
en reflète le score d'Éric Ciotti donc
oui c'est intéressant et c'est vrai
intéressant aussi parce que ça peut
générer quelques frustrations quelques
crispations chez eux qui seront regardés
avec intérêt de la part de la majorité
vous craignez un candidat plus qu'un
autre
si je dois commencer à avoir peur de
quelqu'un j'arrête la vie politique
d'accord merci beaucoup
Vincent à tout à l'heure Yves bonjour
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
figurbain on va rester sur le même sujet
d'ailleurs bonsoir Isabelle bonsoir
je vous ai senti un peu énervé quand on
pendant cette première partie de mission
quand on évoquait la droite son attitude
à l'Assemblée nationale
vous trouvez que le gouvernement et
Emmanuel Macron va beaucoup dans le sens
de cette droite et que cette droite est
bien se comporte mal vis-à-vis de je dis
simplement que on pourrait être plus
indulgent ou plus constructif sur
certains textes et en particulier sur le
texte de l'immigration qui a priori sur
le volet et notamment répression de la
délinquance d'origine étrangère
ne devrait pas susciter autant de
critiques que que elle le fait à droite
et je trouve ça surprenant ce qui veut
dire quand même que la politique du
gouvernement penche plus à droite qu'à
gauche aujourd'hui écouter c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment ce que je dis puisque
lorsque le texte nous a été présenté de
la loterie initialement il faisait 32
articles il a il comprenait le texte sur
le ministère de l'Intérieur et 15
milliards d'euros pour nos policiers nos
gendarmes les mesures sur l'immigration
que je génocité et des mesures de
vidéoprotection notamment en vue de
l'organisation de la Coupe du monde de
rugby et des Jeux Olympiques moi d'abord
j'ai dit au ministre d'intérieur c'est
pas possible de faire comme ça parce que
c'est pas intelligible ça va être trop
long à l'Assemblée et puis par ailleurs
on comprend pas les objets politiques
que l'on vote on a découpé en trois
textes et sur le texte immigration au
départ il n'y avait que des mesures
d'ordre d'ordre public donc pour
faciliter les expulsions pour expulser
les personnes qui étaient des mais ça ça
pose pas de problème de dire que
quelqu'un n'a pas respecté les règles du
pays qui de l'accueil qui puisse être
conduit chez lui ça me pose pas de
problème ça pose pas non plus de
problème on République a priori par
contre il faut être cohérent quand on
dit qu'il y a pas de travailleur en
suivant quand on voit que dans nos
hôpitaux que dans nos restaurants que
sur les chantiers
en fait on a beaucoup de travailleurs
réguliers qui remplissent une fonction
qui rendent service à la nation
qu'est-ce qui nous empêche qu'est-ce qui
nous bloque de dire on vit fiche la paix
on fiche la paix aux braves gens si je
devais prendre la délectique de Gérald
Darmanin et puis on les régularise quel
tort ça peut faire à la population
qu'elle tord ça peut faire aux parties
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un peu
inquiet justement parce que cette ce
projet qui a été présenté à la fois par
Olivier du soft et par Gérald delarmann
Darmanin c'est-à-dire d'un côté on est
plus sévère pour les
accompagnements reconduite à la
frontière mais de l'autre côté on
accorde des titres de séjour pour les
secteurs en tension mais il semblerait
que bien justement cette deuxième partie
elle soit en passe d’être abandonné bah
alors ça me surprendrait beaucoup
puisque c'est quelque chose que j'ai
négocié longuement et dont j'ai fait la
condition pour que on puisse voter le
texte c'est quelque chose que j'ai
travaillé depuis maintenant le mois de
juillet ça fait l'objet de plusieurs
annonces réitérer par le ministre devant
la commission des lois une première
annonce pour dire que une initiative
serait prise pour que la régularisation
puisse être demandé à l'initiative de
salarié et non plus l'employeur que le
titre de travail qui est délivré il vaut
pour une période et pour des travaux
donner non plus pour une seule fonction
c'était l'idée de vous êtes plongeur
dans un restaurant d'un côté de la rue
si vous allez servir en face et bien
vous n'avez plus de titre de travail
quelle cohérence ça avait donc le mini
c'est engagé à revenir sur ce sujet et
puis il y a une annonce en dur qui dit
dans le journal Le Monde au début du
mois de novembre qui dit qu'on aura un
titre de séjour pour les personnes qui
travaillent dans notre pays il
semblerait que tout ça soit mais vous
avez des informations selon lesquelles
monsieur Darmanin finalement c'est lui
qui va remporter le morceau en
abandonnant un peu les intentions de
Monsieur du stop
ce serait bien surprenant et dans ce
cas-là comptez sûrement pour introduire
par voie d'amendement ce que j'ai
apprenant défendu 4 mois durant 5 mois
durant dans le cadre de la préparation
de ce texte alors justement ça m'amène
trois noms sont régulièrement cités dans
le cadre d'une élection lointaine qui
sera en 2027 et Monsieur Macron ne
pourra pas se représenter on parle de
Monsieur Philippe on parle de Monsieur
Darmanin on parle de Monsieur le Maire
trois visages et trois noms qui viennent
de la droite ça vous inquiète pas ça que
personne finalement sur l'aile gauche de
la majorité je sais pas comment il faut
l'appeler donc vous êtes plutôt un déjà
grandi le macronisme originel voilà et
je pense que c'est la bonne définition
alors ça vous ça vous inquiète pas qu'il
y en ait pas un qui émerge là ou une
d'ailleurs à 4h30 d'élection
présidentielle oui non ça ne m'inquiète
pas du tout non ça m'inquiète pas du
tout parce que celui ou celle qui pense
d'abord à son intérêt personnel avant de
penser à la réussite du quinquennat
en novembre 2022 je pense qu'il se
trompe tellement qu'il se décrédibilise
pour l'élection 2020 monsieur le maire
se trompe et monsieur je sais pas quels
sont leurs intentions réelles ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que si c'est le cas
oui ils sont vous êtes président de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale
et il se trouve qu'il y a pas mal de
textes actuellement proposés par le
gouvernement qui passe par le Sénat
justement qui est à majorité de les
républicains on parle de cette loi sur
le projet de loi sur la le ministère de
l'intérieur on parle de migration sur
l'immigration également sur les énergies
renouvelables ça vous froisse pas un peu
ça quand même ça me fera ça me froisse
d'autant moins que c'est moi qui les
suggéré au gouvernement cet été j'avais
fait deux suggestions d'avoir des textes
ramassés pas plus de 15 articles
maintenant de notoriété publique j'avais
demandé à ce que on puisse autant que
faire ce peu sondé au Sénat quel était
l'attitude de nos collègues ça marchait
pour la loi d'orientation du ministère
de l'Intérieur les 15 milliards puisque
les socialistes l'ont ça a marché pour
la loi sur les énergies renouvelables
puisque les socialistes les républicains
les communistes et même les écologistes
l'ont voté donc c'est une méthode qui
est aussi été prouvée et fonctionne si
ça nous permet d'adopter des textes et
passer les réformes moi j'ai aucun état
d'âme ok d'accord
est-ce que c'est une façon de piéger la
droite l'Assemblée nationale
pourquoi pourquoi les socialistes ne
vont-ils pas voter la loi de
programmation du ministère d'intérieur
qui donne 15 milliards en policiers dont
les policiers eux-mêmes disent que c'est
le retour de la police de proximité le
directeur départemental de la sécurité
publique de Haute-Garonne c'est ce qu'il
dit ce sont ses mots c'est dans le
journal pourquoi les socialistes ne
m'ont-ils pas voter les 300 policiers
supplémentaires pour Marseille ils sont
arrivés j'étais le 31 novembre à leur
arrivée les 160 supplémentaires le 31
octobre pardon le les 160 policiers
supplémentaires pour Lille pour
Montpellier pour
toutes ces policiers supplémentaires
dont nous votons le financement leur
encadrement le renforcement
d'encadrement la question de la
formation tout simple ça bénéficie
d'abord aux municipalités socialistes
ils l'ont compris au Sénat pourquoi ne
le comprimeraient-ils pas pourquoi ne le
comprennent-ils pas à l'Assemblée
nationale ah moi je pose la question
d'accord
si un jour vous dites le Sénat entre la
voix je dis que je dis que
les sénateurs socialistes républicains
écologistes ou communiste savent ce
qu'ils ont promis aux électeurs et ça va
reconnaître dans les textes du
gouvernement les mesures qui parlent à
l'heure actuelle électorale
épreuve en est plus de sagesse preuve en
est aujourd'hui que lorsque les mesures
correspondent à des promesses ou en tout
cas à des orientations politiques qui
sont celles d'un camp ou d'un autre et
bien ils savent faire le pas pour voter
les réformes du gouvernement j'aimerais
qu'il en soit autant à l'Assemblée
nationale
si je pense qu'on est un petit peu
empêché si je voulais vraiment mon avis
partout c'est congrès qui se déroulent
en ce moment le Congrès des républicains
ou s'il y a une course à l'échalote par
le Congrès des socialiste où il y a une
décision totale et par le Congrès des
écologistes je manque de qualificatif ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est un
peu la paille aussi c'est un peu la
pagaille chez les écologistes aussi
beaucoup chez les républicains aussi
alors certainement oui c'est ce que vous
avez dit et chez les socialistes pas
mieux d'accord et chez vous ça va ça se
passe bien
la majorité d'accord oui bien si demain
Cyril Hanouna vous appelez au téléphone
et vous inviter dans son émission alors
est-ce que vous iriez d'abord j'y suis
allé une fois
l'émission balance ton poste pour tout
vous dire lors de lors de la crise de
sanitaire et sur les annonces qui
avaient été faites j'étais un peu douché
par la façon dont on ne s'écoutait pas
cette émission la façon dont le clash
est organisé et dont en fait on était là
pour un pugilat général dans lequel
chacun balance quelques et puis repart
bien content d'avoir ce que c'est la
place d'un homme ou d'une femme
politique de que d'aller dans ce genre
d'émission rétrospectivement je vous
dirais que non après l'avoir essayé mais
après si vous voulez mon avis parce que
ce que vous voulez m'interroger sur la
polémique sur lubia Oui et sur mesure
d'abord
Cyril Hanouna comme une faute en
insultant loubaya il a comme une faute
on insulte pas quiconque on insulte pas
on a eu la République donc s'il devait
être condamné pour cela ce serait mérité
ce serait justifié et ce serait tout à
fait logique en revanche personne ne me
fera croire que Louis Boyard ne savait
pas à quoi s'attendre lorsqu'ils dans
cette émission
j'ai vu j'ai vu ce qu'il en était la
différence avec louboyard c'est que j'ai
pas tenté de faire un coup politique
autour de ça il faut admettre que c'est
un coup politique qui lui a plutôt
réussi pour son camp n'empêche que c'est
quelque chose qui abaisse au global le
rôle des parlementaires Adrien Adrien ce
qui est député de la a été
une plainte contre lui pour bien
violence conjugale auprès de sa femme
contre sa femme est-ce que Adrien katnas
qui a conservé son siège de député doit
revenir à l'Assemblée nationale et peut
siéger à l'Assemblée nationale d'après
vous d'abord j'observe qu'il est plus en
arrêt maladie ce qui est mieux c'est une
bonne chose ensuite pourquoi qu'est-ce
qui vous gênait parce que être hypocrite
là-dedans je trouve oui je trouve
ensuite la différence avec Adrien
Captain c'est qu'il a demi l'effet qui
les a reconnu et donc ça pose un
problème un problème qui n'est pas légal
un problème qui est moral et je ne suis
naturellement pas à sa place mais je
pense que si j'avais été à sa place je
ne reviendrai pas à l'Assemblée
nationale vous ne reviendriez encore
moins encore moins quand on a tenu les
propos qui sont les siens à l'égard des
victimes de violence et quand on en a
fait un des éléments essentiel de son
combat politique c'est c'est aussi un
élément fondamental de mon engagement
l'égalité des sexes et le respect dû à
tous et en premier la lutte contre les
violences conjugales et donc quand on a
fait une faute aussi grave je pense
qu'elle est disqualifiante
il ne peut plus représenter les Français
en tenue de ce qu'il a reconnu avoir
fait avec sa femme compte tenu du fait
que c'était un élément essentiel de son
combat politique oui je pense que ça le
disqualifie durablement
rédhibitoire c'est dit on verra si
Antoine léoman dans un instant qui nous
rejoint merci beaucoup
vous répondre sur ce point moi j'ai une
autre question avant qu'il nente c'est
que le groupe RN on vient de la prendre
va déposer un amendement pour inscrire
la loi veille la loi veille dans la
Constitution et un amendement qui
pourrait être défendu dans quelques
jours quelques semaines par Marine Le
Pen
elle avait dit non elle a
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG elle dit
oui à la loi veille qui lui paraît être
un bon cas c'est-à-dire les 14 semaines
qui autorisent l'IVG vous êtes sur sa
ligne vous pourriez voter son amendement
elle a été
abroger dans son acception initiale
ensuite elle a été elle a été remplacée
par d'autres lois donc ce qui revient ce
qui revient à une agression par une
remplacement par un remplacement ensuite
je crois que c'est le rapport au panneau
qui dans la commission la semaine
dernière a fait la une liste de toutes
de tous les déclarations du parti du
fragment national contre l'IVG des
positions y compris même prises par la
porte-parole du rassemblement national
pour la suppression du droit à l'IVG
lors la Valette et donc je pense que
c'est il y a là un tour de passe-passe
une grande hypocrisie aussi de la part
du rassemblement médical qui se passe
qui s'est passé par rapport à ça
d'ailleurs le meilleur exemple c'est que
les députés RN ont une liberté de vote
sur cette question ça rendit beaucoup en
face de vous c'était si Antoine et au
manque vous en remercie aussi d'avoir
accepté de débattre merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté le principe de cet
échange dans audition publique vous êtes
un député la France insoumise élue dans
l'Essonne vous êtes arrivés à
l'Assemblée en juin dernier et vous avez
deux vous allez retenues deux thèmes
pour débattre avec
Sacha Houlier et commencer par les
salaires dont on parle beaucoup et
notamment le niveau du SMIC en France
tout à vous tout à fait parce que nous
proposons ce jeudi 24 novembre à
l'Assemblée nationale une proposition de
loi d'augmentation du SMIC à 1600 euros
proposition de loi qui est assortie
d'une caisse de solidarité
inter-entreprise afin que cette
augmentation du Smic ne soit pas
pénalisante pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises et à l'heure actuelle où la
question du pouvoir d'achat est la
question centrale pour les Françaises et
les Français
j'ai du mal à comprendre comment on peut
s'opposer à l'augmentation du SMIC à
1600 euros sachant que cette
augmentation du SMIC en plus touche
prioritairement des emplois qui sont non
délocalisables et je vais même un peu
plus loin j'ai été assez surpris de voir
que parmi les amendements déposés sur
cette proposition de loi au sein du
groupe Renaissance il y a eu des députés
pour déposer un sorte d'amendement
MacDonald's qui empêcherait la mise en
place du SMIC dans la restauration
rapide ce qui vraiment est l'endroit
typique où les emplois au SMIC ne sont
pas délocalisables et ou des gens sont
particulièrement précarisés par des
grandes entreprises comme McDonald's
comme Burger King comme KFC qui sont en
plus des multinationales américaines
donc voilà je pense que cette
augmentation du Smic elle est
indispensable et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi il ne va pas y avoir
d'augmentation du SMIC et pourquoi votre
groupe ne va pas voter cette
augmentation du Smic mais comme moi je
comprends pas pourquoi vous avez pas
voté pour les mesures qui permettent de
faire des compléments de salaire et qui
permettent d'ajouter aux salaires des
Français sur les heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées sur la prime Macron sur
les mesures qui par ailleurs
permettaient de d'augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat en allant des mesures de lutte
contre
augmente le SMIC ce qu'on a toujours
étudié dans le pays c'est que
l'augmentation du SMIC provoque
l'augmentation des salaires qui sont
entre le SMIC et l'augmentation du
salaire parce que précisément les gens
disent bah moi j'étais avant au dessus
du SMIC donc ils vont augmenter leur
revendications maintenant cette boucle
pris salaire en fait en réalité elle est
déjà là en réalité il y a déjà un
problème d'inflation et ce qui se
produit c'est que les salaires
augmentent moins vite que l'inflation et
que donc le salaire réel des gens qui
sont très peu payés diminuent il y a une
perte de salaire et une perte de pouvoir
d'achat et ensuite je veux revenir sur
les la question que vous me posiez
pourquoi nous n'avons pas voté sur les
heures supplémentaires des fiscalisées
et pourquoi nous n'avons pas voté sur la
prime Macron et bien pour une raison
simple c'est que pour ce qui concerne la
prime Macron c'est une prime qui est au
bon vouloir du patron alors que
l'augmentation du SMIC c'est un choix
politique c'est une décision qui
s'impose au patronat là ce n'est pas le
cas et d'ailleurs quand on interroge les
gens sur pensez-vous que la loi pouvoir
d'achat d'Emmanuel Macron a fait quelque
chose pour votre pouvoir d'achat la
réponse est NON et sur la question sur
sur la question des heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées là c'est
encore plus grave c'est que c'est
carrément assez glucide c'est-à-dire que
on est en train en enlevant des en
défiscalisant si en défiscalisation
c'est la baisse du chômage parce qu'en
défiscalisant une nouvelle définition
les heures supplémentaires on est en
train aussi d'attaquer le financement de
la sécurité sociale et rien du tout rien
n'est prévu sur le sujet dire ça pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord vous n'avez
pas répondu à mon argument qui de dire
que le SMIC a augmenté de 8% sur l'année
passée quand l'inflation était de 6%, ce
qui montre bien que c'est sûrement c'est
sur l'ensemble c'est en venant à l'année
dernière qui montre bien c'est en
revenant à l'année dernière qui montre
bien que en réalité l'argument selon
lequel les salaires n'augmentent pas
autant que l'inflation est faux non
ensuite ensuite avec votre idée du SMIC
avec vous n'avez pas non plus répondu à
mon argument qui veut dire en faisant
augmenter le SMIC toute une série des
salaires qui sont indexés sur les
conventions de branches ne sont pas
concernés et dans votre dans votre
argumentaire vous dites pour demander
une salaire supplémentaire pour avoir la
prime Macron il faut que l'employeur le
veuille bien ben pour négocier la
convention de branche il faut
c'est une augmentation qui est sur
l'ensemble des salaires et donc ça ça
met un seuil minimum d'ailleurs c'est
comme ça que c'est rédigé dans notre
propre
minimum en dessous duquel il n'est pas
possible de payer les gens publiques
fonction publique pas n'importe où et
fonction publique toute une série de
salaires se retrouver en dessous du SMIC
parce que ça c'est de votre faute parce
que vous n'aviez pas fait vous n'aviez
pas revaloriser précisément vous dire
que vous n'avez pas peur
que le SMIC avait tellement augmenté
qu'il avait dépassé l'indice des
fonctionnaires de catégories que nous
avons corrigé avec d'ailleurs des
partenaires sociaux puisque nous l'avons
rectifié avec la précision on est
d'accord que c'est qu'il y avait un
problème dans la rémunération des
fonctionnaires et donc nous avons
augmenté cette rémunération il faut oui
mais il faudrait quand même pas accuser
ceux qui proposent l'augmentation du
SMIC de vouloir dire que derrière il
faudrait que les salaires des
fonctionnaires soient inférieurs le
problème vient du fait que les salaires
des fonctionnaires n'avaient pas été
assez augmenté donc c'est c'est ça cela
dit cela dit vous n'avez pas non plus
voiture vous n'avez pas non plus voté
vous n'avez pas non plus voté les
mesures du projet de loi de finance
rétique cet été qui permettait
d'augmenter de 4 points le point de le
point d'indice vous n'avez pas voté ses
disponible
nous n'avons pas voté l'ensemble de la
loi parce que nous étions défavorable
justement à ces défiscalisations des
heures supplémentaires mais nous avons
voté la mesure sur l'augmentation
juste revenir sur un point vous dites il
y a eu une augmentation de salaire de 8%
ignaxie pour son inflation sauf que
c'est inflation elle prend en compte un
ensemble d'éléments qui ne sont pas les
éléments qui touchent le plus
directement les personnes qui sont
payées au SMIC et notamment sur les
questions de l'inflation dans
l'alimentation on n'est pas à des taux
de 6%, on est à des taux de 15 mais 20
et même pour l'huile de tournesol par
exemple on est à 134 % d'inflation donc
ça frappe directement le salaire et le
revenu global des gens qui sont les
moyens en plus vous parlez en salaire
pur vous vous excluez d'ores et déjà des
mesures comme le bouclier tarifaire
dont dont
la meilleure mesure mais qui avait été
très bien et donc mesure éventuellement
si elle vous regardez si vous regardez
souvent j'ai pas toujours mais souvent
les choses par le tout petit trou de la
langue non deux choses sur le bouclier
tarifaire premièrement en janvier le gaz
et l'électricité vont augmenter de 15 %
donc un bouclier où il y a une
augmentation de 15 %, vous nous disiez
tout à l'heure il y a une augmentation
de 8% des salaires bah typiquement sur
l'énergie et le gaz on va être en
dessous du niveau de l'inflation donc
c'est une perte de revenus sur la
question de l'énergie et du gaz avec le
bouclité tarifaire mais le problème du
bouclier tarifaire en plus c'est que il
n'est pas financé par les entreprises
elles-mêmes c'est-à-dire que il faudrait
plutôt faire un blocage des prix qui
permettent que ce soit une partie des
entreprises et la différence précisément
dans le projet de loi de finance la
contribution européenne en plus la
contribution exceptionnelle l'alignement
du prix est pour le coup le surtaxe à
90% au dessus de 180 euros de mégawh
finance mais c'est pas la finance le
même chose c'est pas la même chose c'est
pas la même
en revanche c'est une surface de toutes
les énergies et les producteurs
d'énergie qui permet de financer le
bouclier tarifs
qui est très intéressant aussi tout à
fait d'actualité c'est la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur et vous voulez revenir sur
quelques points précis on vous écoute
sur les amendes forfaitaire délictuelles
parce que là c'était un des grands
sujets de cette loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur on en a déjà beaucoup
débattus dans l'assemblée alors les
amendes forfaitaire délictuels c'est un
mécanisme qui consiste à remplacer un
certain nombre de peines enfin ou à
permettre que à la place d'un certain
nombre de peine on est des amendes qui
soient remise par la police qui posent
plusieurs problèmes déjà c'est que il y
a pas de présomption d'innocence vous
avez directement une amende ensuite
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de de
d'individualisation des peines quand
vous avez un jugement vous avez des
circonstances atténuantes des
circonstances aggravantes et même la
possibilité d'être à quitté ça existe
quand même et là ça n'est pas le cas et
puis c'est des amendes qui sont plus
très discriminatoire mais le problème
dans le texte précis qui nous est
présenté pour moi et sur deux points en
particulier l'amende qui concerne le
fait que des lycéens ou des étudiants
majeurs se mobilisant à l'intérieur de
leur lycée dans le cadre par exemple
disons de la réforme des retraites
contre la réforme des retraites et bien
majeur cela pourrait avoir au lycée cela
pourrait avoir uniquement les majors au
lycée d'ailleurs je suis très content
d'avoir obtenu le fait que ce soit bien
précisé dans le monde
disons que cette dans les lycées
professionnels par exemple vous avez
beaucoup de majeurs mais cette amende
elle pourrait être de 500 à 1000 euros
et une autre amende de ce type là a été
prévu pour les cas de blocage des routes
comme le faisait par exemple les gilets
jaunes en filtrant la circulation et là
on parle d'une amende de 800 à 1600
euros ce qui pour moi est une remise en
cause du droit fondamental à manifester
bon d'abord dans ce texte
vous avez eu tendance
à toujours plutôt vouloir défendre les
délinquants tes policiers non bah si
systématiquement je vais vous répondre
vous pouvez pas dire je vais vous
répondre sur l'amende forfaitaire des
rituels vous vous montez montez bien
mais vous montez quand même non vous
montez parce que vous nous dites que il
y a pas de contradictoire en fait
l'amende forfaitaire de rituel elle
n'est adressée à une personne que si
elle accepte d'avoir reconnu
préalablement les faits sinon sinon il y
a une procédure judiciaire qui qui est
menée qui conduit les gens devant un
tribunal correctionnel et qui fait
l'objet d'un débat devant un juge c'est
la reconnaissance préalable de
culpabilité la signature du
procès-verbal qui fait que la mandat
acceptée parce que le délit est reconnu
ensuite sur la question des mineurs on
vous a dit plusieurs fois pendant tout
le débat que les mineurs n'étaient pas
concernés j'ai pas parlé des mineurs sur
la question on va parler des mineurs
j'ai précisément parler des majeurs sur
la question des vous avez bien de
parfait de parler des lycéens majeurs
c'est vrai parce que dans le débat vous
nous parliez des étudiants les étudiants
ne sont pas concernés pour le blocage de
leur ét puisque l'établissement
d'enseignement supérieur ne sont pas
concernés non plus tout à fait ensuite
mais les étudiants et les étudiants qui
se rendraient dans un lycée pour aider
un mouvement sur ces questions
concernées d'abord les étudiants n'ont
rien à faire dans un lycée
jusqu'à les étudiants n'ont rien à faire
dans un lycée même pour les débrouiller
et puis dernière chose sur ce que vous
avez dit aujourd'hui ce que vous
critiquez c'est le fait qu'on puisse
dresser des amandes sur des faits qui
peuvent faire l'objet d'une peine de
prison pour en aller jusqu'à 1 an pour
deux ans pour ce qui concerne
l'occupation illégale d'un établissement
scolaire ou jusqu'à 2 ans pour ce qui
concerne l'entrave et ce qu'il faut
préférer d'aller devant un juge qui en
comparaison ou qui dans une procédure
judiciaire peut prononcer une peine qui
est une peine d'incarcération ou est-ce
que c'est tellement
précisément
donc vous reconnaissez que la plupart du
temps c'est fait là ne sont pas puni et
ne vont pas jusqu'à
les procédures mais vous connaissez
comme moi la réalité des tribunaux les
peines sont et son prononcées elles ne
sont pas réalisées
c'est pour ça qu'il y a un problème dans
votre argumentation vous nous dites vous
nous dites
pas exécuté parce que vous ne mettez pas
assez de moyens et dans la justice
attendez si vous me laissez aller
jusqu'au bout moi je suis pas coller
peine je suis pour que les peines qui
sont prononcé soit exécutés mais pour ça
il faut qu'il y ait assez de monde dans
la dans la justice pour traiter
correctement les dossiers et il faut
ensuite avoir la capacité de les traiter
si on est dans votre logique et par
exemple de mettre les gens en prison
donc d'ouvrir des places ce avec quoi
moi je suis en désaccord et
particulièrement sur cette question là
vous nous avez dit que vous voulez
mettre en place des amendes forfaitaire
délictuel pour désengorger les tribunaux
mais dites moi quelle tribunaux
exactement sont engorgés par des gens
qui ont bloqué des routes et des lycéens
qui ont bloqué leur lycée là il y en a
aucun mais la réalité c'est que la
plupart du temps il y a une forme de
tolérance qui s'exprime vis-à-vis de ce
type de mouvement et par exemple sur le
mouvement des gilets jaunes la plupart
du temps ce qui était fait c'était que
les gens étaient condamnés ou allés
devant le tribunal pour d'autres faits
que celui du blocage des alors là
qu'est-ce qui va se passer quand des
jeunes vont se mobiliser dans leur lycée
ou quand des gens vont se mobiliser par
exemple en bloquant des ronds admettons
ça fait partie du régime des
possibilités vu que ça a existait ce qui
va se passer c'est que là il pourra y
avoir un policier qui vient et qui dit
Popop ça c'est puni par le code pénal et
maintenant c'est puni par une amende de
800 € et vous pensez vraiment que des
gens vont
contester l'amende et se dire que il
vaut mieux qu'ils aillent devant un
tribunal etc effectivement non donc ce
que vous êtes en train de faire ce que
vous êtes en train de faire et ce qui va
produire
ce qui va se passer c'est que vous êtes
en train d'essayer de faire peur aux
gens qui souhaiteraient se mobiliser et
de pouvoir punir rapidement celles et
ceux qui le feraient alors la réponse
après cette longue est précise
argumentation mais le débat est de
qualité donc voilà non mais d'abord vous
nous dites que il y a pas d'engorgement
il y a un engorgement des tribunaux mais
à la bonne heure mais parle de sur ce
point à la bonne heure mais pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas voté non plus les buts
de la justice qui prévoit des magistrats
supplémentaires des greffiers supers
c'est pas assez donc en fait c'est pas
assez donc ça mérite contre mais oui
deuxième chose sur la question de la
mort de forfaitaire délicuelles je vous
ai dit précisément on a même inscrit
dans la loi qu'il fallait notifier des
droits des personnes que s'il
n'acceptait pas l'amende s'il dit non je
la conteste en disant je fais une
procédure mais non je la conteste non je
refuse de reconnaître les faits qui me
il y a une procédure devant un juge et
ensuite vous nous avez dit et je vous ai
dit au tout départ que vous avez été
plutôt du côté des délinquants du côté
des policiers vous nous avez dit que
devant un juge vous préfériez que ces
gens ne soient pas condamnés ah ça oui
par contre moi je suis pas pour condamné
l'action sociale je vous dis je vous dis
que lorsqu'on a commis un acte de
désobéissance civile on en assume les
conséquences on sait qu'on se place
en infraction à la loi et donc quand on
se place en infraction à la loi alors la
loi républicaine étant la même pour mais
ça c'est bien on peut être
il y a des bloquer la circulation
comment ça se passe parce que on le voit
il y a des jeunes qui le font il y a des
gilets jaunes qui pour l'instant c'est
de ce point de vue là il y a des
procédures judiciaires qui sont parfois
engagés et lorsqu'elles ne sont pas
engagées on ne pourra avoir des de faire
peut-être délicatures donc il y a bien
un mécanisme qui va être plus efficace
je vais utiliser votre vocabulaire plus
efficace pour pour punir des actes qui
effectivement sont punis dans le code
pénal
parmi les 24 sur les amandes précisément
parce que vous avez aussi vous avez
aussi vous avez aussi les amendes pour
la consommation stupéfiante mais parce
que
précisément elle ne mène à rien elle ne
mène pas à une baisse effective de la
consommation de cannabis là c'est un
autre sujet c'est que c'est inefficace
c'est pour atteindre le l'objectif que
vous fixez d'ailleurs j'ai été très
heureux de lire dans votre interview à
Mediapart le fait que vous pensez qu'il
faut légaliser le cannabis parce que je
trouve moi aussi ce serait une manière
plus efficace y compris de lutter à la
fois contre le trafic de cannabis et
contre la consommation de cannabis avec
des politiques publiques qui seraient
faites sur cette question là qui serait
plus efficace sur ce point là au moins
on se rejoint et moi je suis et moi je
suis du coup pas pour les punir par une
ce que j'ai dit il y a Mediapart
précisément c'est que philosophiquement
il fallait y parvenir et qu'aujourd'hui
il y avait une grande crise autour de
ces sujets et qui faisait que le chemin
était étroit pour y parvenir voilà donc
une dépénalisations serait déjà une
bonne chose il faudrait aussi des
désintoxications parce que on peut on
peut être on peut être toxication on
peut être on peut être pour le fait
qu'il faille le dépénaliser ou légaliser
on peut aussi se dire que l'accès d'une
consommation d'un stupéfiant et que
c'est pas bon en général pour les
personnes qui le font précisément nous
notre proposition notre proposition sur
le sujet elle est un peu détaillée
puisque avec la légalisation nous
voulons que l'argent qui serait obtenu
par la légalisation parce que par la
force des choses il y aurait une
imposition sur cette sur cette nouvelle
vente plutôt que de l'argent qui part
dans l'espace obscur c'est que l'argent
qui serait dégagé puisse être utilisé
pour faire de la prévention sur la
consommation de cannabis en gros et de
manière détaillée mais simplement pour
finir d'un mot sur la question des
amendes dans une finir sur la question
des actions à tous les manifestants je
suis heureux de vous dire ce n'est pas
le cas sur ce sujet là quand même nous
sommes dans un pays où nous avons créé
cette république à l'issue d'une
révolution qui n'était pas légale non
plus et donc sur ce non mais sur ce
sujet là sur ce sujet là c'est
intéressant et apaiser
dans l'hémicycle ou dans les commissions
où vous siégé on va vous pouvez rester
avec nous monsieur léoman une dernière
question de Vincent roux en direct du
Figaro live Vincent c'est à vous oui
alors c'est une question qui aurait pu
être posée par Antoine lehoman puisque
c'est un de ces un membre de son de son
parti enfin ses proches qui va dépose ce
projet de loi qui va être en discussion
jeudi c'est sur l'interdiction de la
corrida qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
Sacha Olivier qu'est-ce qui va qu'est-ce
que va faire votre groupe est-ce que il
y a une liberté de vote est-ce qu'on
vote pour est-ce qu'on vote contre il y
a une liberté de vote dans mon groupe et
pour ce qui me concerne je suis regrette
de vous dire que je serais absent
puisque je rencontrerai toutes les
associations féministes à la veille du
25 novembre vous défaussez sur ce vote
NON je me défausse pas j'ai prévu de
longue date de rencontrer tous ceux qui
mettent en place le brasseur
mais ce que je veux ce que je vais vous
dire
ce que je vais vous dire par là c'est
que j'avais prévu de longue date de
rencontrer celles et ceux qui
participent à mis en place des or de
protection des brassets anti
rapprochement et au déploiement des
téléphones graves dangers et que c'est
votre
bâtiment ça m'est égal et je pense que
l'Assemblée pour examiner d'autres
textes donc c'est une perte de temps je
pense que c'est pas la priorité du
moment Antoine vous avez un avis moi je
pense que c'est un sujet qui intéresse
beaucoup les Français on est à plus de
80% des Français qui sont favorables à
la fin de cette torture et pour moi ça
fait partie des choses qui vont dans le
bon sens c'est pour ça que nous l'avons
proposé
l'unité sur notre groupe vous dites à
Vincent effectivement que vous n'êtes
pas là bon c'est une bonne excuse parce
que le sujet vous avez traité c'est
prévu depuis trois mois donc
c'est une explication de leur absence ça
je veux dire c'est un sujet très
important mais la corrida vous prononcez
pas parce que c'est clivant parce que
c'est embarrassant parce que vous ne
savez pas trancher entre ceux qui sont
sensibles à la cause animalis et
traditions j'assume d'avoir une
hésitation sur ce sujet et que en
commission d'ailleurs je me suis pas
exprimé sur cette question j'ai pas pris
par au vote et je j'avoue être
circonspect par rapport à
une forme une forme de vraiment de
je sais pas si c'est du populisme en
tout cas il faut être du côté du mal du
côté du Bien que ce soit du côté des
anti-corridas comme des pros et je
trouve ça un peu gênant donc j'ai pas
j'ai pas de position établie ou
définitive sur cette question et je
pense que c'est aussi l'honneur des
parlementaires de pouvoir dire quand on
sait pas
c'est vrai qu'on a tradition beaucoup
défendent le maintien de la corrida
est-ce que toute tradition par nature
doit être défendue
c'est une question que je vous renvoie
parce que elle est bien trop
philosophique pour faire l'objet d'une
réponse
[Musique]
de Sacha Houlier mais effectivement on
est un peu sur sa faim sur l'air sur la
question des traditions si je peux dire
un mot
80% des Français
que jusqu'à une date passive ancienne
que ça à la Saint-Jean ont brûlait des
chats c'était une pratique parce que les
chats étaient un des personnages
diaboliques et ont brûlé les chats donc
c'est une tradition mais on est quand
même revenu sur ça
c'est moins important pour le mode de
vie par des paysans que la chasse c'est
un sujet intéressant en tout cas merci
infiniment en tout cas tous les deux et
en particulier Sacha oublié d'avoir
passé l'heure avec nous bien sûr entre
trouve on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro d'audition
publique bonne soirée sur LCP et Public
Sénat
[Musique]